right the president who promised to
unify the country not off to a great
start
when was the last time he had a
conversation with president biden
even on the phone um
i don't believe i've spoken with him
since he was sworn in we had a couple of
conversations before then
i know mitch well mitch knows me well i
would expect mitch to say exactly what
he said
all right that's that but it's not
always the case a lot of people on
capitol hill
capitol hill do get along you just never
know about it that's about to change
joining us now two friends who you
wouldn't expect to see
at the same time democratic congressman
rohan of california
and a guy who's not in california
republican congressman matt gates of
florida neither shy
very smart hey guys first off start with
you uh congressman kohana
how do you explain how much you like
this guy you told me off camera you
you and mac get along we do get along we
work on common issues we work to get pac
money out of politics we both believe
that lobbyists shouldn't be
running this place we both believe that
we shouldn't be in foreign wars
obviously we disagree on issues
but we actually engage in dialogue and
we even hang out
congressman i don't know if you know it
but uh congressman cohan did not
uh ronna did not support donald trump
and
you did he supported bernie sanders when
did you realize you could still work
with him that you
you came into the same class and you can
get some stuff done
brian so many of the challenges we face
in washington don't just pit
the red team against the blue team
they're generational challenges
how do we ensure that america defeats
china to win in the 21st century
how do we build a technical working
class of people able to survive
how do we ensure that we don't waste the
blood and treasure of our country at
wars in the middle east and
what's unique about this political
realignment that i think
donald trump had something to do with
that bernie sanders had something to do
with
is that you can actually have right-wing
populists and left-wing populists
working together and sometimes it is the
establishment against the rest of us
ro khanna has made me a better
congressman because he doesn't take
money from lobbyists or
pacs most members of congress get most
of their money
from lobbyists pacs and special
interests because of roe's inspiration
i'm the only republican who won't take
any lobbyist or pac-man
and i think a lot of times we turn the
compliments when
we were trying to end our involvement in
yemen
and when we were trying to make sure
that we didn't get into
iran matt went against people in his
own party in his own leadership to stop
those
wars and if i was just trying to put
together a coalition on the left
we would never have made the progress in
yemen we would have never
made the progress in stopping the
intervention in iran so
people people said why are you working
with matt gates i said well
if you care about stopping wars overseas
look at what he's doing
right absolutely all right wrap it you
ready for rapid fire here's something
you agree on ending forever wars
matt why uh because america is too
special and we ought to focus our
resources on our people
and focus on the strategic threats to
ensure that we are a successful and
prosperous
country going forward congressman kohana
you just want us out of afghanistan
right
yes i do all right next something you
disagree on immigration congressman
gates what do you think
i do not believe that we ought to have a
poorest border i think we ought to have
rule of law
i think that the asylum process was
improved greatly by president trump and
i'm worried that joe biden's reforms are
actually creating a great deal of
of insecurity in our country congressman
kahana how do you differ
i believe in borders but i believe that
we need to uphold our rule of law and
asylum
and that means that when young children
come here we treat them with respect and
have them go through the process but
obviously i believe that we need to have
borders and enforce borders in this
country all right so you're different
marijuana reform you both agree
how
i do not believe that the federal
government has been a good steward of
marijuana policy i'm speaking to you
from florida
i believe in state-based approaches
that's what our federal assistant
promises
and i hope ro connor will join me in
moving the biden administration on
marijuana because so far
the biden administration's only coherent
policy on marijuana is firing staffers
who used marijuana are you going to help
them ro i i've criticized the
administration for that i agree with
matt that that was a
wrong decision i mean we shouldn't be
firing young people who
use marijuana once and it actually has
an impact
most negatively on actually black and
brown
americans who face incarceration and
it's one of the reasons we have mass
incarceration in this country so i
agree that we ought to move towards
decriminalizing and legalizing marijuana
now hold your ears donald trump agrees
with you on the next one ro
this is bringing manufacturing back to
the u.s he deserves a lot of credit for
it matt
you're into that so is roe democrats
republicans
bring the manufacturing back what are
you doing about it
well i'm hopeful that we're able to work
together on this because it's not an
issue
that lends to a red versus blue
dynamic you see row represents silicon
valley so he knows a lot about
job creation in the modern era and i
actually think we can do a lot
in the energy space and in the clean
economy space to work right alongside
democrats to ensure that america is
splendid and wonderful for generations
to come you think america row is
willing to spend more to build it here
we need to i mean that's the real
competition with china are we going to
lead an ai are we going to lead in cyber
security
are we going to lead in the energy
markets of the future and by the way it
shouldn't all be concentrated in silicon
valley and boston why aren't we
developing
manufacturing capability in rural
america in the midwest and the south
and that's an area that i've worked with
matt gates and i think that that
can be an area where we work in a
bipartisan basis
last question do you feel pressure and
consternation from your party leadership
when you walk across work across the
aisle matt you first
i have been criticized for my work with
roe but i'm proud of it
because at the end of the day our team
isn't just the republican caucus or the
democrat caucus
our team is the american people and i
have gotten criticism from leadership
for it
and i don't mind it at all because i'm
deeply proud of the work we've done
together
to stop wars to build a manufacturing
base in this country
and to make sure we win generational
challenges like the battle against china
and climate change 15 seconds
he took a lot of your time real quick
well i'm people are proud of the work
too and you can look at my twitter feed
probably right now i'm getting
criticized
anytime i do anything with matt they say
well why are you doing that
do you are you supporting his position
that's what we got to get over in this
country i get criticized when they come
on fox news come on we got to talk to
each other
we got to work together in concrete ways
to help move this country forward
that's what we do in everyday life why
not in washington guys i hope people are
inspired and you end up in leadership
in the not-too-distant future thanks so
much rokahana uh matt gates go out and
grab a beer and i don't want the
taxpayers to pay for it it's got to come
out of your pocket okay
thanks brian we'll make sure that's the
case yeah make it match pocket oh you
got it